[Music]
meagan Markel is busy getting used to
life as a royal or maybe I should say
the Royals are getting used to life with
Meghan the future Duchess and her fiance
Prince Harry
we're traveling over the holidays but
not like you would expect so let's take
a moment to appreciate this sure Harry
whisked Meghan off to a romantic
post-christmas vacay on the French
Riviera but et has learned the couple
boarded a commercial British Airways
flight to get there and they flew
economy class file that under the royals
they're just like us the newly engaged
couple sat in the back of the plane near
the bathroom the part where they are not
just like us they boarded before
everyone else and took up three rows of
seats they also had three bodyguards in
tow it's not the first time a royal has
opted for less than glam travel plans
back in 2014
brother William blew commercial from New
York to DC on his way to meet President
Obama's hugely refreshing to be able to
get to know someone who isn't
necessarily within your circle doesn't
know much about me either they're not
much about her so to be able to start
almost afresh right from the beginning
and getting to know each other sent by
step Harry and Meghan have been bucking
tradition throughout their courtship
Megan even attended the Queen's pre
Christmas lunch at Buckingham Palace a
privilege usually reserved for family
members only
the couple rang in the New Year in Monte
Carlo and according to Kensington Palace
they're due back to report for their
first joint engagement of 2018 next week
they're also busy making plans for their
upcoming wedding in May Meghan's already
been in touch with several designers
buying to make her wedding gown
now I do want to tell you the show
there's a lot of speculation that Megan
and Harry partied with Harry's good
buddy Prince Albert of Monaco and his
wife Princess Charlene maybe they were
talking babies maybe thank you